joining us now our Florida congressman
Ron de Santos and Matt Gaetz all right
good evening gentlemen I'll start with
you congressman de santis I mean this
has been a longtime effort on your part
to get to the inspector general's report
I have it right here
all 500 and whatever pages of it I
haven't had a chance to read it all but
I promise you I will before my show
tomorrow night your take congressman de
santis well I think what it's done is
it's vindicated Trump and really both
prongs of the Muller investigation you
mentioned you have a Democrat of
Inspector General basically saying Comey
should have been fired I've always said
Comey should have been fired you believe
that but the idea that you're going to
have an obstruction of justice
investigation because Trump fired the
FBI director who the IG acknowledges had
no business being that FBI director is a
farce and then the other thing I think
it undercuts is the whole genesis of
this so-called collusion narrative they
did not give that text message to the
Congress when we asked where struck says
we will stop Trump from becoming
president this is the guy that six days
earlier opens up a counterintelligence
investigation against Trump's campaign
this whole thing is infected with bias
and it needs to stop in congressman
gates I mean with respect to what
congressman De Santis just said look
that one of the most damning text
messages that that he just referenced
had to do with struck saying you know
don't worry about it you know we'll stop
it when asked do you think he'll ever be
elected president now that information
was not given to Congress what are you
guys gonna do about it besides ganache
oh and complaining about it well frankly
I think we need to impeach rod
Rosenstein because these text messages
that showed that there was an effort not
only to reflect bias against the
president but to manifest that bias in a
way that that impacted people's official
actions as government representatives is
reprehensible we asked for these
documents a year ago and this was
blacked out it was redacted there's no
national security reason not to share
this information with Congress it's just
embarrassing to the FBI
that they had these swap alligators
crawling around and doing everything
they could to be destructive but you
know what's frustrating congressman
DeSantis is that when the American
people when the viewers watch this and
last night I was on Sean's show when he
was hosting and I said you know what's
so sad I have always believed in the
system 10 Americans believed in the FBI
based upon the fact that it seems that
long-term damage has been done to the
institution I don't think there's any
question about that Judge and it's not
just struck in Page I mean there were
other FBI agents one was said after
Trump one who was part of the clerk
Hillary investigation part of the Muller
investigation he said viva la resistance
that's what he was that's what his
response was this is the guy working
with Muller I mean give me a break and I
think that you also have all the leaking
in the report showing just the cascade
of leaks you have agents getting gifts
from reporters so there is broad
problems in the headquarters they're
there for a press conference and he was
not everyone is frustrated we know
what's wrong we know that Joe Schmoe
would be in jail right now but it's not
happening so here's what I would here's
what I would say yeah this is the text
message either Rosenstein knew that that
text message hadn't been produced if
that's the case he needs to go or he
wasn't competent enough to get us the
information we requested to me he should
go so I think his continued position
there is really untenable at this point
all right and and Congressman gates I
mean I've heard everybody say Rosenstein
should be going for a long time what are
you gonna do about it I think we need to
file articles of impeachment let's
remember this is the same Rosen Stein
who said I think we need to do it
immediately I'm ready to go we're trying
what do you need to get it done talk to
me 218 votes I need 218 votes in the
Congress of people who have the courage
to stand up against a deep state that is
actively working against our president
today I mean why does Peter struck still
have a job why is this guy still an
alligator crawling around in the swamp
of Washington DC we got a
get rid of him and the fact that we
haven't yet shows a lack of leadership
at the top of the FBI and Department of
Justice or with all due respect the
prosecutor in me tells me he might be
cooperating but then I say to myself
self who is a cooperating would what do
you think Congress exaggerating with
yeah I couldn't hear I'm actually not
getting all that Matt's saying but I
mean what are we gonna do about it I
mean what I would say is you hold these
people in contempt and then if they
don't produce what we want you you move
to impeach them and remove them from
office that's the power we have if we're
not going to use that power then we're
gonna continue having the same stuff
where we come on your show we complain
and we don't ever get any results and so
we've got to use the power that we have
all right but but congressman DeSantis
what what the congressman Gates just
said was that we need you know over 200
votes for an actual impeachment of
Rosenstein and every time something
comes out we say this is another reason
to impeach him but you know this judge
if you have a speaker of the house
exercising leadership the majority
leader and they say Rosen scenes got to
go they can marshal the support of the
Congress and yes it won't even come to
an impeachment because when you lose the
support of the congressional leadership
and you're in a position like that you
probably can't go if we just put a
resolution on the floor saying
Rosenstein should go and that passed he
would be done so we just need people to
exercise leadership whoa well let me ask
you this why isn't Paul Ryan doing it to
either one of you have him on your show
you know call him to be on my show
tomorrow night
Oh Ryan all right and final question in
terms of the FBI do you believe that
Christopher Ray who was pretty much sat
by and watched all of this and didn't
too many people take enough of a you
know a a recognition of the serious
damage that had been done by Comey do
you feel comfortable congressman gates
in his leading the FBI going forward
christopher ray can lead the FBI in an
appropriate way he needs to do so by
immediately firing Peter struck and by
taking far swifter action I believe
arrey understands how damaging the axe
of these anti-trump people have been to
the FBI but frankly I would like to see
a production of the documents that get
to the very root of all this and by the
way the root of it is Russia these
people wanted to get rid of the Hillary
Clinton investigation they wanted to
launch a phony Russia investigation and
I won't have confidence in anybody until
the documents are turned over okay all
right except the problem with not
getting rid of struck is if he is
cooperating then no one's gonna get rid
of him or maybe there is a thinking that
let's make him think he's cooperating
and keep him here because there's no
reason to keep congressman to Santos
I'll see you tomorrow night on my show
justice and Congressman gage thanks so
much for being with us